good oh another wait what I was I'm not
a very good
[Applause]
host I'm so happy to see you I might
cry hey honey okay I'm really
out right now oh my God D I just was
watching you and any anyone but you
which I love by the way it's such a good
movie oh my God it's so
good oh my God can you rip that in half
and I can use part like you you were so
good to me I was I really was like a
lost 17-year-old I mean I was having so
much fun but like I didn't know how to
take care of myself and you took such
good care of me you you were so kind to
me and like protected
me oh my so happy to see you incredible
what you did M got year in that ense
incredible incredible
Survivor dermit
was he was he really really took care of
me I mean I was wild guys like I was
really really wild sorry guys I cry
now it is so nice a man cry by but I
knew I was going
to and I came anyway and I decided I'm
going to go ahead and cry in
public I hear you drew how did you know
at that point to be someone who did take
care of
people I don't know M my great parents
of course is my first thought um and uh
it was pretty obvious I think like you
said you're a teenager so I was uh I was
30 although I looked about
wow those were really good cameras back
then too you guys they really made
beautiful beautiful cinematography on
that and what beautiful performances in
a time when it just had occurred to
Hollywood to go ahead and make movies
with women in it there was this new
thing called female empow
I don't know if you've heard of it um
and it's waned since then and returned
but you guys did something that was
unacknowledged at that time that you
just touched on to be four lead women in
a studio release movie I I challenge you
to name another one in the early 9s
right it'd be hard to find one this
leads me to the I do have a bone to pick
with you drew oh God it's about a horse
so first of all they killed me in Young
Guns one which was a terrible terrible
mistake as we all know we've dealt with
it for like 35 years now and we're fine
with it on Young Guns 2 that's where
John bonjovi was on and he went blasting
out of a barn on that beautiful big
Palamino horse that was my horse and so
they renamed the horse that day John
bonjovi I made a Western in the meantime
called the last Outlaw with Mickey R for
HBO so right before bad girls I had done
a western and I was on John Bono I was
on the big beautiful Palamino cuz I was
the lead of the movie so I well yeah so
I get
to I get to Sonora California is where
we started this yeah but we ended up in
Delo Texas well really about 30 mil east
of there bracketville
bracketville oh my God it's a
bracket relative to you valdi and but
they gave her my horse she rode that
John the whole time and I was stuck on
some soral nag do you know what I just
remembered me calling dermit with not on
a phone because I had to like run to
your house and I was hysterical there
was a giant tarantula in my room in my
house I remember that and I was like I I
I I I never slept again I don't remember
that you came in with a giant broom and
took the tarantula and the tarantula was
this big cuz we were in the middle of
nowhere I mean really nature like we we
experienced the butterfly migration I
saw the whole tree covered with them did
you see it I saw I walked through and I
saw a whole tree covered in butterflyes
we couldn't drive they would cover the
windshield it was like you would put
your arms out and just be covered in
monarch butterflies that's how deep in
nature and whether I was in deep trouble
or there was a tarantula in my room I
would always come running to Der it to
save me yeah well I would too I would
too